you just want to bring you some breaking
news reaching us here at Sky Center and
John Watson I'm sure many of you will
know legendary commentator and
broadcaster he's had a 50-year career
sadly he has uh died announced by his
employer the BBC he was 77 and he
covered at 10 World Cups can you believe
it 10 European championships and 29 FA
Cup finals for BBC a sport he retired in
2018 I think he was known as motty I'm
sure many of you know him as that he had
worked on much of the day since
1971 and his commentated as I said on so
many different World Cups etc etc two
and a half thousand telephone televised
games 2 500 televised games in 2001 he
became an Obe for services to sports
broadcasting and the legendary
commentator John motson has died at the
age of 77 that according to the BBC
within the last few moments